[Music]
you
so a lot of you probably already know
something about Asher Ian it was a
search fund company that was about the
size of many of the companies that are
here in the room but since the
acquisition in 1992 there are 8 billion
in revenue 1600 employees which by the
way to put that in perspective is about
the same size as Facebook 22 countries
53 cities we have with us three of the
architects of that success kevin Tweel
Jim Ellis and Gerald risk Kevin and Jim
were both former case writers with her
Groesbeck as I was so it's sort of
something that we all share in common
they Kevin and Jim both raise their
search funds separately which a lot of
people don't realize and they joined
forces later on after they were already
in the search and that's something I'm
gonna ask you a little bit about later
on Gerald
joined assuring in a few years later
after they'd bought the company also a
Stanford MBA and later he worked his way
up to being CFO and then president how I
got involved is one day Kevin called me
up and asked if I'd like to invest in
his search fund and that was back in a
day where I think maybe at that point
there and less less than five searched
funds raised in total and so you were
desperate so I was on the list and I
remember I didn't have any money at the
time and he bridged my finance and my
search fund unit until I got my company
sold so I can invest in road rescue
thank you very much by the way for that
but we're not going to talk about how to
run a billion-dollar company instead I'm
gonna ask these guys to go back in time
25 years and see if we can't tease out
some of the reasons why they are where
they are lessons not on how to run a
billion-dollar company but how to create
a billion dollar company now assuring
and began much like all the companies in
this room in fact you know we sometimes
forget that that and not so long ago Jim
was reminding me of a story which
I'm gonna ask you to share with us the
company used to be called road rescue
ten million in revenue 75 employees most
of them were truck drivers or call
center employees as I remember from our
early board meetings that was in
industrial Houston not exactly the
fanciest place can you would you just
share with them a story so we can kind
of set the stage for what assuring a
road rescue looked like in 1992 was
there a particular story there was the
story where the company sponsored a
concealed weapon class and we had a fire
our receptionist who carried a 38 there
was the issue where somebody threw rocks
through our window and Kevin and I had
to answer calls all night there was the
fact that we had to repossess one of our
tow trucks what our driver got drunk and
passed out in a motel and we had to go
find him there was the landlord that
asked us to please have our employee
stopped having sex in the fire escape so
there's a lot of store I mean it started
I mean we really did start kind of in a
in a business that was pretty raw it was
I mean a lot of the we were when we were
looking at buying other companies it was
one of the things that a lot of people
told us to stay away from in terms of
towing and it wasn't necessarily the we
weren't working with we were possibly
the only MBAs that entered our business
of towing cars the year that we graduate
yeah so it was all glamour when they
first had that business Kevin I want to
ask you you two didn't start out as
partners you met along the way and many
of us in the room struggled with do I
want to run a company by myself or with
a partner I want to ask you so how did
that all come about so for most of you
this is probably too late since you've
already partnered up or made that
decision but when I was going through
the process of thinking about a search
fund I had already tried everything else
thought about business plans and tried
to start it thought about starting
companies and that didn't nothing panned
out there so once I decided to do a
search fund I knew I was going to do it
either solo or or with a partner
and I was certainly hell-bent on doing
it one way or the other strong
preference to do it with a partner I
know I don't think there's any right
answer and I think to her success
stories across the spectrum or in both
situations but for me the the idea of a
partner has some of the obvious benefits
of sharing the highs and lows
you know John Stanton talked earlier
about the loneliness of being the CEO
and and you obviously have less of that
with a partner but I think it was core
really why I really wanted a partner was
just a belief that yeah given the right
opportunity you can accomplish so much
more as as partners than in any one
individual so so maybe building a little
bit about upon that it was what a half a
dozen years before Gerald joined or
wasn't it was so you and Jim to come
together you both Stanford MBAs the
company is still pretty small and yet
another Stanford MBA under the team what
were you thinking I mean that feels like
a lot of horsepower we I mean diversity
was an issue we're thinking about
Harvard but we decided to stay away from
I'm not sure we've ever quite gotten
that far it was not about another
Stanford MBA it is I hate to repeat what
you guys have heard many times already
today but this idea of getting great
talent we were fortunate enough to have
learned that early on and we were aiming
high for the best candidate we could get
for that role and we so it was it was
really less about you know getting a
specific Stanford MBA I would you know
from my experience I'd say you should
always go after that person no matter
the cost
I know they're particularly smaller
companies there's always that trade-off
and if you're you're talking to your
board about the cost of that
extra salesperson and for the right
individual particularly those key slots
I'd say in 99 out of 100 cases maybe
even you know a higher percent than that
you really can't pay that person enough
because it's really really your company
was small at the time that Gerald joined
and the impact he had I mean not to toot
his horn in front of you know everybody
here while he's sitting right here but
it's been it was tremendous I mean one
of the learnings Jim and I had early on
was just a tremendous impact one strong
player can have I mean the the converse
is true as well we learned that lesson
you make a bad hire in a key slot it can
take years and a lot of money to clean
up that mess well Gerald so you got a
degree here and you had a career in
investment banking that was doing well
what was it about joining a roadside
assistance towing company working for
two people who were essentially your
peers what was it about it that got
Kevin and Jim to get you on board yeah I
can remember back okay
so first it fit with my career
aspirations at the time I had being in
the towing industry in the towing
industry and so I was working at Goldman
as a investment banker in San Francisco
and I'd really joined there yes to build
skills and investment banking and maybe
a career there but really I joined with
a view to using that as a century post
to find an opportunity to be an
entrepreneur I'd come to Stanford like
many people and didn't maybe didn't
really know what entrepreneurship was
but was kind of interested in it and
maybe like lots of people in this room I
didn't see myself as a startup
entrepreneur and so am I gonna be an
entrepreneur if I don't start a company
and kind of kick the tires on search
funds but that wasn't a good fit for me
so I thought oh I'll be I'll join the
senior team of a growth company which
seemed kind of unrealistic graduating
from the business was oh I'll go back
into banking and
see where that we build skills and
relationships and see where that leads
and so when Kevin called me out of the
blue I was like oh here's the you know I
was very primed for the opportunity was
really oh here's a growth coming and
then I didn't look at Kevin and Jim and
think of them as peers I looked at them
and thought oh here's two people who
have at this point six or seven years of
hard-won entrepreneurial experience a
great reputation I thought oh here two
people I can learn about being an
entrepreneur from and I looked at the
board and I thought my gosh what I mean
what a great opportunity to kind of do a
good job for these people and if you
know if that's all that happens
that's you know that's a great outcome
and then I actually loved the contrarian
nature of the decision it just sort of
fits with my personality that that was
1998 and if you were leaving Goldman if
you were an associate at Goldman you
were leaving you were leaving to be CFO
of an Internet start-up and I I just it
was like weirdly more appealing to me
too I'm gonna join a towing company that
actually has cash flow well okay but it
was a towing company so what was it
about if you can recall anything about
the way Jim or Kevin positioned it that
made it attractive for you and the
reason I'm asking is that a lot of this
is about attracting good talent it's one
thing to say okay I want to I want to
find my Gerald but how do you get that
somebody like that to join your company
especially the kinds of companies said
so so building on some of what I start
adding more specificity to some of what
I just said Kevin and Jim were very
effective in painting a compelling
vision for the company that yes it was
towing but we were tied to well at that
point we were still chipping our pea con
like insurance but you know they made it
compelling hey this is why we're gonna
take over towing for auto insurance and
we also had mobile and that actually
seemed quite compelling too so they
painted a very come
telling story of where this company
could go and it had validity because oh
these you know these smart investors
that I have you know that I don't know
but I have a lot of kind of implicit
respect for back these guys and this
growth story and it just it it seemed
very compelling if I remember correctly
when one of the things we really tried
to present is we're bringing on another
partner you weren't necessarily there at
the founding but we didn't want somebody
who is just gonna be an employee who
managed finance we're really thinking
about somebody who's gonna have thought
leadership play a role in the strategic
direction so I think a big part of the
sale at least it was our intent was
you're gonna have impact you're actually
going to have a founder like role in the
direction of the company you're going to
have a pretty meaningful voice in that
you know the this was brought up in one
of the earlier sessions about how do you
sell this opportunity and for road
rescue but I think you know in most
cases I mean for people who will talk to
you assuming they've got some sort of
entrepreneurial aspiration I think we
all have an amazing story I mean this is
an opportunity for for somebody often at
a younger age to take on a bigger role
more responsibilities and to be have a
seat at the table at making the key
decisions that will drive the company
successful or or failure and that's
that's a pretty heady opportunity for
anybody of course there's an opportunity
potentially to create wealth along the
way
but to have that seat at the table to be
able to make those key decisions you
know folks at that age coming in you
know working a midsize or larger
companies just don't have that
opportunity so Jim I'm sure there are
people in the room that are kind of sold
that boy if I could find somebody like
Gerald or later we're going to talk
about Brett qumola who they recruited
later I would do that I don't know how
to find that person and I think there's
kind of a mythology that these people
just sort of fell in your lap along the
way what what do you recall from how you
and Kevin used to find talent and then
maybe bring it to a day of you know an
age of LinkedIn and social media and so
forth
so that we've got something that doesn't
work from yes I would say the most
valuable resource that we've had in
terms of attracting the best talent has
been the network that we individually
developed a Stanford network if you look
at Brett we'll talk about it was a was a
GSB grad Gerald certainly our current
we've announced who the next CEO is Tony
who will be was a GSB grad so I think
early on I think we abdicated some of
the hiring process to recruiters when we
would hire somebody and then kind of say
the pros are here we'll vet the
candidates but really left it in their
hands and I think we found oftentimes
those produced candidates that that
weren't didn't have the tenure with us
they didn't have the impact and I think
when we found people through our network
and put them through that process that
we ended up with much better folks I
would say a lot of our key players came
from networking just making sure that
you tell everybody out there what it is
that you're looking for in terms of
talent I think starting when you start
to develop a reputation that you allow
people to make decisions and have impact
beyond their past experience that we
weren't looking for somebody man Gerald
is a perfect example coming on as as CFO
when he had never had a CFO or a
controller role before I think meant
people were kind of stepping in with
some of the weird aspects of being a
towing company because they had more
opportunity so I think presenting the
opportunity the right way
I think leveraging your network and I
think lastly lot of places where we made
a mistake and hiring is we kind of went
through this search fatigue and we would
hire and we'd say we had six months for
a search and at the end of the search
you just hire whoever the last person
was on the list and I think most of the
time we ended up really disappointed in
those so I think it's kind of keeping it
going particularly for key positions and
to your fine folks and for us it's been
huge success through the through the
Stanford Network and despite what Kevin
said we've actually hired a few people
from Harvard so you touched on an
interesting point which is that of
course you know we can talk about the
people that worked out but there were a
lot of people that you hired and didn't
work out what's our process did you have
to try to make sure that if you made a
mistake you dealt with it quickly
or did you early on no we were terrible
I mean I mean I think we we had one
person who you know we kind of joked
that he eventually became vice president
of special projects and a career advice
when you become the vice president a
special project you're past your
expiration date it just meant it just
meant that we weren't willing to pull
the trigger and we kind of passed it on
from department to department so I think
we eventually learned to get better I
think the toughest thing is actually
making the decision as to when is the
right right time to part ways and I
think over time we become better done a
lot better job at specifying what the
expectations are for results not just
resume and what that looked like but for
impact and results and when and when
those things don't work out often times
have presented the right way the person
in the position knows that they haven't
delivered and those decisions become
easier and it becomes quicker and I
think it's part of that discipline that
actually took took a long time I mean
all of our missed all of those mistakes
were always letting somebody go too late
and it was unfair to them I mean we've
even had situations where we've called
people up and said can you have lunch
and had him call back and say I was
thinking about putting a deposit on a
piece of property this afternoon should
I do that or should I wait till after
lunch
right I mean clearly clearly it was
terrible management on our part that
that person was coming to work every day
knowing that they were underperforming
and just waiting for that phone call so
I think we got a walk he did it at lunch
we did I suggested that he may not want
to put that deposit down I had the first
time I had to terminate somebody I
didn't want to do it in the office so I
went down the street to McDonald's and
that seemed to work out okay so the
second time I determinate somebody I
went back to McDonald's I didn't realize
the word got around the company that if
anybody if Dodds John Stanton mentioned
that earlier today that we always many
of us fired you know take too long to
fire and I wanted to ask him what he has
done over time to to improve his average
their to do to shorten the period of
time and we didn't we've thought about
this a lot and haven't really come up
with any
other than what we try to do every day
which is build a relationship with our
employees our team members and have a
constant conversation with them so
they're the expectations of them are
known and you're giving them feedback
they got the feedback both the positive
and the constructive feedback and
through that process I've found that the
the time it takes to get somebody who's
not the right person on your team off
the team it's just it goes a lot quicker
just because you're having that
conversation at regular intervals but I
we haven't found any other great
mechanism to shorten that that process
Cheryl I wanted to ask you and you may
not know this off the top of your head
but I remember about two years ago you
showed me a slide in a presentation
about the key hires and the different
networks that came out of and I don't
remember the exact number but it was
some really sort of remarkable number
that had come out of Kevin's network
over time do you remember anything of
the data on that slide well this line
was probably you know Kevin's direct
reports at the time and it just it just
sort of data backing up Jim's comment
about a Stanford Network is that there
are probably seven direct reports and
five of them were from Stanford and and
one so probably four forward from
Stanford two were from our professional
network over time at a Sharan like
clients we worked with or people Brett
knew you know I'd gotten to know at the
CTA and then one was through a recruiter
I remember watching as you were building
the team how much you had drawn upon
your network as it was you know to find
these sorts of people which kind of
brings me to the issue of Brett camelina
Brett's not with us today but he was
hired on as president and then CEO of
the company and so eschews brought on
directly and right well I'm gonna get to
that actually because so assure ian was
maybe a half a dozen or 10 years into it
since he had bought it at the time five
five or six you've already brought on
Gerald company's doing well maybe
thousand employees something like that
but it but it was doing better and and
and we knew that it was going to be
successful and then you bring on
somebody else that's a little bit
different than when you brought on
Gerald and when when the two of you
brought on Gerald you were sort of
building out your direct reports this is
quite different you brought on Brett
Kamali and you said no I'm gonna step
away a CEO you run the company now I
think a lot of us would have trouble
doing that because we would say well
things are or things are successful
things are doing well and and I do
remember in the board meeting being
honestly a little perplexed and I
couldn't figure out if you had lost
confidence or what was going on so just
a little bit turned out to be an
incredibly wise move tell us a little
bit about your wisdom around that well
it I don't recall it exactly the same
way David the Jim and I wanted to to
bring on you know Brett on to the team
and you can hear somebody to thoughts on
this in a second Jim we he was a just an
amazing talent and we had initially
scoped this as a CLO role well Brett
given his experience and his prior roles
we were never gonna get him without the
CEO title and it wasn't that he I don't
even recall him putting up that as a
barrier per se not Brad but we knew we
wanted him we knew how talented he was
we knew what kind of value get add and
we wanted to bring them under the team
so so Jim and I talked about it and we
were comfortable giving him the CEO
title where I differ from your your what
you said is it was never to turn it over
to Brett to run the company it was
really yeah this is at a time where Jim
was transitioning out of the business
and we were looking for really a
partnership and to me it was the titles
were really less important it was I was
looking for a partner to you know
replicate the the partner
ship that that I had with Jim for the
prior six seven years and you know in
retrospect I think it was an incredibly
risky move I mean incredibly I mean to
bring somebody in from the outside I
wouldn't try to fill his shoes yeah I
mean it's just you've got a company
you've got a culture and bringing in
somebody from the outside at that senior
level as always I think a pretty risky
endeavor you know as you know as we
thought about it as I thought about it
the real key was how were Brett and I
got to work together and you know
certainly one is I wanted to emulate the
communication with Jim and I had which
was not daily it was multiple times a
day we would talk at length you know you
know in very short spurts and and the it
was it was almost like a continuous flow
and I was hopeful the Brett and I would
get there and we ultimately did or we
did almost right away and then I think
the the tell-tale sign for me in a
partnership is whether the other person
is pulling you in or pushing you away
and you know really concerned about his
or her sandbox and there's these are my
roles and responsibilities that's that's
it to me that's a you know not not a
yellow flag it's a red warning flag and
you know I think great partnerships are
built on one person asking for price
pulling the other person in you have
clear donated roles and responsibilities
but you want the other person yeah
that's a really interesting metric and
that was the the right person I mean in
so many different ways I mean first of
all we'd never been titles and we
literally flipped coins for titles for
offices for all the rest of that stuff
so they're really those decisions and
that is actually no Jeff we were at the
SFO and we were trying we're going to an
investor meeting was it Jim some Jim
southern I think more like Jim is not
gonna let us get away Jim's gonna let me
go question this question and we were at
a payphone do you guys remember those
and we called her for advice and I think
he gave two piece of advice one is you
know skip the CEO title just have one
president one Chairman and flip a coin
and we flipped it right then and there
that was it but in terms of Brett we've
never been sensitive so that really
wasn't a lot of territory certainly
between the the two of us and we the
company had grown so fastly but the time
Brett came on were three hundred million
dollars in revenue we were we went from
70 employees to 1500 employees and he a
lot of that growth we had really gang
tackled a lot of problems new contracts
new markets new products or whatever it
is and I think we had way outgrown
organizational structures systems
processes so we spent a lot of time
building the business but less time
building the organization and the next
stage it just wasn't gonna work right I
mean it's it's not force of will and
personal connections it really has to be
much more structured in Brett look he
was second in his class from West Point
he had been a CEO before he had a lot of
the things that we felt were not
necessary things we spent a lot of time
on or were particularly interested in or
maybe not even very good at and and
Brett kind of came on and really created
a lot of the structure and organization
that had been lacking I mean look I I
can say probably we probably shouldn't
have spent time on that we maybe waited
a little bit too long but we
definitively needed it by the time
Brett stepped into that role the way the
story goes that Brett did a semester at
the Air Force Academy where they didn't
give a pluses so we had all a-pluses at
West Point his competitor had all
a-pluses at West Point and he had won a
only because the Air Force Academy so so
Gerald I want to switch gears a little
bit we've talked to we've been talking
about why you might bring talent on and
why it's important so once they're on
board I want to talk a little bit about
culture and values and how you motivate
people like that
and I know that you've I've heard you
mention the phrase divine discontent
well tell us a little bit about what
that means and also how you
to aspire to divine discontent yeah so
divine discontent is our branding of
some of the themes that you've heard
today just kind of a feeling that a
dissatisfaction with the status quo a
desire to get better kind of a
personality that's drawn it draws
inspiration from the next milestone not
sort of past achievement and and just
over time divine discontent became our
branding for that concept and a cultural
value that the divine discontent itself
we stole the label we stole from an
article a friend of mine like six months
into the job he faxed it to me so he
didn't email it to me I don't know if we
well probably had email but I literally
think he faxed it to me it was an
article from the McKinsey quarterly
written by this guy David Kirk who had
been captain of the of the 1984 New
Zealand All Blacks rugby team which you
know sort of at the time was sort of the
best rugby team ever and he was captain
of that and went on he was a Rhodes
Scholar and blah blah blah worked at
McKinsey and then they asked him to do a
speech at one point about running
world-class teams and and then he
reduced his speech into this article and
one of the things he talked about was
the mindset of the team and he labeled
it divine discontent and how they looked
at competitors not as a way to they
wanted to thrash their competitors but
they really didn't look at it as victory
per se they looked at it as any
competition as a way of measuring
themselves against their own standards
and their other stuff in the article but
that was sort of divine discontent and I
read it and I was like you know and I've
kind of walked down the hall to Kevin's
office and showed it to them and we just
it just resonated with us and like this
reflects our personality and kind of
what you know on our best day is what we
want to try and create here and over
time it just became you know it was in
the water we actually created a I mean
we have operating principles and
this is one of our core values divine
discontent and we found it to be highly
functional and the reason it was highly
functional is that it gets it you know
we paired it with with we it just was a
great way for people to engage and how
do we make things better without being
defensive so we could say I could go
into my into the CFO's office when I was
president and sort of say what is the
finance organization look like at full
potential it's not like you know I don't
think that you know I don't think that
guy is very good or I don't think you
know our AP is up to snuff but it's a
totally different question to say what
does this look like if it's really
awesome and and and that just became
very they've led to a lot of
comfortables that you know a lot of very
comfortable conversations about how we
can get better and we've also along with
divine just contends by the way I might
add one thing is so I got that article
in 1999 and it became part of you know
company you know I was like our core
values and so probably in 2013 or 2014
Kevin and I were in Hong Kong and we're
trying to recruit this guy David Moffat
to be the chairman of our Australian
business and he he had been the number
two guy at Telstra so you know again
like aspiration is to attract great
people to our company they're like a
start-up you know like we didn't have
anything in Australian he asked us to
talk about our values just talked over
our valleys and we start and we tell him
about this story and he kind of lights
up he's like I know David Kirk he's a
friend of mine and so the next day we
walk into the office and he's like hey
because he was meeting us in the office
the next day and we walk in and David
Moffitt say Kevin Jarrell come over here
we and we go into a conference room and
he calls David Kirk and he introduces us
and and he says that you know here these
two Canadian guys running this American
company and they they read your article
and it's all part of you know it's all
and he's like you guys might be the only
one
to read that RV but I'm glad it's had
such a big impact on you that's good so
another one of your core values is is
focus on the core yeah what's on most
important I think you call it focus on
the core right so Jim I want to ask you
I mean I think we sort of generally know
what that means
a little bit about the struggle tab to
make that happen I think it would be all
hands would go up if I said does
everybody think it's important to focus
on the core how did you actually make
that happen so I think there's a couple
of things in particularly early on I
wouldn't say that we were very good at
it I mean I think if you asked us if we
had priorities we would tell you yeah we
we did but I think the real issue is how
do you end up allocating your time and
her resources differently is is really
the tough part saying this is really
important and then changing behavior I
think it's really hard one example and
we had a was a Stanford GSB RIT was
running a piece of the of the business
and he always seemed to be majoring in
the minors and you know you'd sit down
with him and you ask him what's your
priorities he would give you a list of
40 things and they were probably in the
right order but he didn't change the way
he got up in the morning and what he did
and now certainly there's going to be
forces that drive you throughout the day
and distract you but I think we've
really tried to internalize identify
what's the most important thing for the
company most of it most of the time for
us early on it was externally focused
and kind of internalized that as a real
value so we're a client centric company
and kind of talked about it in that way
so I think that changes a little bit
your mindset I think number two a lot of
the people that are in this room
probably everybody is a little bit of an
overachiever and I think there's some
type-a personality and there's a little
bit of a resistance to some things my
responsibility and on my plate and I
feel like I it's my responsibility to
spend time and attention on that whereas
when you're in a seat and the CEO seat
is you know eminence it's hard to
approach absolutely everything with
equal level of enthusiasm and energy
it's actually inappropriate right I mean
if we got two or three things right it
was going to dramatically drive value
all the other things we could do
correctly but if we didn't get those
three things right it didn't matter how
well the other things
kind of came together we wanted to do a
good job and I think the other thing is
that there's a level of discomfort early
in your career that I'm not spending
time on that and I think the priorities
what we've tried to drive the
organization to even at the individual
level is it's it's as much about the
things that you don't do as it is the
things that you spend time on and how do
you how do you do that I think you know
you you have those conversations early
in your career with the board they help
you make sure you've got the right
priorities ask the tough questions about
how do you how are you spending your
time whether it's on team or product or
company and I think having that
confidence to make that time allocation
decision I think is one of the tough
parts that happens in somebody's career
and this is something I'll turn over to
Kevin because he's probably the best
person I've ever seen at this but Kevin
ever since I just remember ever since it
was I don't know since the 90s when we
were working together there was always
one or two post-its on his computer
screen and they were kind of guiding
principles do I return that call do I
answer that email when I pick up the
phone when somebody says hey can you
come into a meeting and it was usually
renew a contract or fun.this or deal
with this problem or hire this position
but there weren't ten there were one or
there were two and just making sure that
when you the way you spend your time
certainly over a day there's going to be
distractions so if it's not 8020 on your
top priorities over the day but it
better be over the month and it
certainly be better be over the quarter
and it definitely has to be that way
over the year and I think a lot of times
you just get distracted by all those
kind of micro decisions it seem like
it's only going to be ten minutes but
you know 20 or 30 of those and and all
of a sudden you're not spending that
you're not focusing on the core yeah I
think I think one of the things we did
do well was prioritize and I think that
was born out of our partnership and
spending a lot of time talking about it
and then and getting advice from from
our our board members in particular and
just to put a point on what Jim said
when we took over Road rescue with the
help of the board we identified that the
the real leverage in this hop in this
business was going to be taking it
in terms of revenue opportunity that
phased us and so Jim and I if you called
one we had 100% of our time each
approximately at least a hundred and
fifty percent of our time was spent
collectively was spent on revenue
generation either current or new clients
and we recognize that operationally we
could have been more efficient we could
have done a better job there but we we
we put a capable person in charge and we
were okay with it being at a certain
level of quality for a period of time
while we focused on yeah somebody
referred to you once as being
extraordinarily good at kind of walking
past unimportant messes and staying
focused on what's important I think and
I'm gonna use this word because I've
thought about it he's ruthless about how
he spends his time so so we've spent
we've talked about recruiting that means
you should return that email recruiting
finding talent reaching high jobs we
talked a little bit about making sure
that everybody is thinking in a certain
way and and Jim you and Kevin talked
about getting everybody going in the
same direction so I've got this vision
of this really outstanding team it was
headed all together thinking the same
thing or what roughly the same thing but
I feel like you have another part of the
team here which we're not your employees
but your network and your investors and
I I've never seen anybody use their
investors better than you did especially
in those you know initial 10 years
tell us a little bit about kind of I've
got this I've got this narrative in my
head that you would see a problem and
you would ask yourself what can I just
pick up the phone and get the answer and
if I can do that I don't need to solve
it on my own
but that's my that's my own narrative
it's funny you pose the question that
way because today I find I spend most of
my time trying to ensure that our senior
team is actually aligned and heading in
the same direction it is so freaking
tough it is it's sort of amazing that
you do need to continue to to share the
message and then there
direction were we on Jim and I made
liberal use of our board members
willingness to reach out and offer to
for us to reach out to them and then
David was one of our board members and
probably recalls frequently Jim and I
probably had a weekly basis reaching out
to at least one of our board members and
we what gave us confidence to do that
that we weren't asking silly questions
was that we would test it against each
other first at least it gave us a little
bit more confidence because I know being
in that seat alone I'd worry about okay
just really silly and and would I look
stupid in front of our board I think
that what we came to find was our board
was so open and willing to help us and
wanted to help us and and what we found
was what we thought was a thorny issue
for a board member is a 30 second answer
I mean once you've seen something four
five six times it's the the questions
that you may have had the the gray area
sort of falls away because you have the
data and you sort of understand that we
have tried to build that into the
organization in a an interesting way and
it really ties to what Jim was saying
about prioritizing so in it it it's a
couple prioritization with collaboration
and the idea of getting help from the
right people and for maybe a half a
dozen big issues every year whether it's
a contract renewal or we're trying to
save a client or something like that or
a product introduction we'll bring
together half a dozen or eight of the
right people who who can bring
information and information to bear on
this problem and we'll have one to four
sessions it could be three to four hours
long a lot of information and data is
provided beforehand so everybody comes
prepared and we'll have one or more of
our power of 10 sessions and that sounds
really simple
it sounds really easy but you are
prioritizing something as Jim just said
those people ultimately don't do really
well they tend to move things along at
the same a lot level and you're
preparing for it and you're
collaborating and it has surprised me
every single time we've done it their
quality of alternatives and ultimate
solutions we come up with when you when
you provide that kind of structure
around basically what is essentially a
little bit of prioritization and a lot
of just getting advice yeah there's a
lot of there's a lot of lessons and the
way the three of you would pulse your
network and get advice and fast forward
through the easy stuff so you could
focus on really growing the company and
I think two things in particularly that
we did that made us more effective at
that number one and now being on the
other end the receiving calls for for
advice I think number one we tried to
make it time efficient and easy for the
person to give us advice so it wasn't a
rambling conversation it was structured
discussions with the facts that we
thought were needed and the other thing
was we didn't try to sell so we really
didn't try to come into those situations
asking for advice we're really what we
were trying to do was sell a board
member an investor or an advisor on a
position that we believed in we tried to
take a position where were generally
open and the questions weren't you know
the response wasn't if we disagree with
it why about that you know no but we
think this it was why do you believe
that why do you think that it was a lot
of the kind of why why why until you see
really not good advice if you look back
in your early career as a manager maybe
those first five or so years was there
an inflection point or sort of an aha
moment where you changed and matured as
a manager that those of us in the room
might be able to benefit from and maybe
get there a little faster
so there's many and you know I've been
ensuring 18 years you know three titles
but probably had thirty jobs during that
time just how much and and so my goal
has always been to sort of be within two
weeks of the job description on either
side hopefully two weeks ahead
hopefully not two week more than two
weeks behind
and I remember distinctly like sort of
for maybe it was four years in or five
years and kind of Kevin did me the fade
and say it exactly this way but he's
like no you might be four weeks behind
the Job Description you know you might
want to I'm going to catch up a little
bit and and so we like brainstorm okay
so how might I do that and we kind of
together like oh let's call you know a
board member and maybe they can and so I
actually remember calling Jeff chambers
and who's the best CFO you've ever
worked with and he said this guy and and
can you introduce me to him and so I
went and spent today with the CFO but
actually it turned out I spent 10
minutes with him but he set me up with
each one of his direct reports and I
think I had eight meetings and they were
each like 45 minutes and I literally
took like eight pages of notes and that
was like my playbook for the next you
know I was oh that's what a CFO does I
had no idea it was already on the job
for years that's a great story and
obviously something you could do early
on yeah yeah somebody else could maybe
do that
you know first day on the job Jim I mean
I think there was a I think there was a
point in the career of managing people
you kind of felt like you needed to be
responsible and I think there was that
shift where you know a big piece of my
job is actually to learn from and
harness the talent that's in the room
and it's not about me being a manager
but it's about me being a facilitator of
other people's success and I think that
fundament the people that you work with
recognize that and respect it I mean you
still have responsibility for evaluating
performance and making sure you get the
right people on the team but I think
when you kind of viewed it as you know
I'm the coach trying to help get the
team to that point I think it's a very
different management approach as opposed
to I'm going to manage your to-do list
and all the rest of this it's kind of
confidence but it's also morning it's
it's a at some level of self awareness
and self comfort that you're willing to
learn from the people who know a lot
more about their particular job than you
do that's great all right Kevin last
word things I learned early on were that
we're surprising to me it was
and I mentioned them both earlier just
the value of bringing on a tremendous
talent like Gerald number two was the
the real effect and impacting had by
experimenting just the the power of that
and the the need to always be doing it
but as I thought about the first five
years and and most transformative moment
and you may remember this David you were
there because this really impacted the
trajectory of the business for the next
20 years this was in I think 1999 we
were a board meeting at Southwest
Freeway in Houston and Jim and I and
Gerald were there and we were you know
tentative and we were bringing this big
proposal to the board
it was cellphone insurance were handset
protection and we wanted to propose to
the board that we buy this little cell
phone insurance company and we were you
know yeah uncertain of ourselves a
little insecure and and we put it on the
table and there was a little debate back
and forth and then all of a sudden bill
Egan stands up and says this is the best
business ever it's like this is an
amazing isn't he said bill so the actual
story is Bill's like what is this who
would ever buy this product this is the
craziest idea ever is that it except
except for he didn't used to work crazy
so that was a transformational
conversation
bill that's how I remember it as well so
it would be easy to have you up here
because you bought this company and it's
it's the largest company that's come out
of the search fund model but and that's
part of the reason they're here but the
other part of the reason is how they got
there and Kevin touched on a little bit
about it but everything that these guys
did had ethics and values they did it
the right way
they didn't behave in any way that would
leave them to be embarrassed and then
tactically they every move on the
chessboard not every broad but most of
the moves on the chessboard were
skillful management and that more than
anything is why we're lucky to have the
three of them up there so big round of
applause for my
[Applause]
[Music]